como llega a brasil a estos comicios a
nivel social no porque se habla mucho de
un país altamente polarizado
santiago gracias por su contacto esta es
verdad una característica especial de
las elecciones de 2022 va a ser un
cuadro político bastante polarizado no
sólo por contar de las cuestiones
económicas sino que también para un
debate asociado a los valores y esto
debe resultar en una corrida
presidencial con altos impactos no sólo
de corto plazo pero también de medio de
los pasos no solo para economía sino que
también para las bases de una vida más
tranquila en brasil ahora como decíamos
previamente luiz inácio lula da silva y
jair bolsonaro son los candidatos que
están pisando más fuerte no de cara a
los comicios donde encuentran su
principales apoyo cada candidato
tendrá huestes en arles se mantener
hasta fines de la corrida al menos de la
primera vuelta y básicamente el
presidente evo zonal tiene dos tipos de
apoyos principales del primero de ellos
gol de electores conservadores y también
los electores de macizos mari por
perdóname el presidente duro al
contrario tiene como fuerza apoyo de los
jóvenes y apoyo de las personas más
vulnerables que esto resulta
especialmente por parte de este último
pombo un favoritismo a ayuda por contra
de esta influencia muy fuerte en los
grupos más vulnerables en brasil rafael
bueno la campaña recién está comenzando
no pero cultivos que ha caracterizado
durante todos estos días los discursos
de lula da silva y de bolsonaro en que
se han estado enfocando
el presidente persona 2 seguramente
intentará hacer un cambio en la
perspectiva más general acerca de su
gobierno entonces hacer una defensa y su
administración y lo aprobado intentos de
dar ingresos a las familias más
vulnerables esto como un intento de
construir apoyo a la reelección por otro
lado el presidente duda tiene como tarea
hacer el electoral de mirada al pasado
mirando a sus gobiernos anteriores que
fueran un momento en la historia de
brasil que ha resultado un engaño de
económicos y reducción de la desigualdad
entonces la estrategia de duda prepara a
movilizar apoyo de estas personas que en
este momento son contrarios a la
continuidad en el gobierno y necesitan
una imagen para dar concreto a esos
pedidos por parte del ex presidente lula
ahora ante un eventual escenario con uno
de estos dos candidatos ganando las
elecciones presidenciales esa
polarización social de la cual usted nos
habla y
profundizaría perdón
y realmente porque hay un efecto
político por tales de esta polarización
mucho asociado al debate la imagen entre
duda y personaron pero esa
radicalización también tiene bases más
estructurales por contra de tipo de
conflicto que ha pasado en brasil no
sólo la en la economía con decisiones
difíciles pero también es
fundamentalmente en decisiones de
naturaleza y política social y esto nos
debe simplemente salir de nuestra agenda
después de la contestación delante red
la corrida presidencial especialmente se
mantiene una perspectiva por parte del
presidente bolsonaro yacieron la
contestación del resultado electoral
esto también el mundo los peligros para
la democracia brasileña al corto plazo